hallo herzlich willkommen zur sally bell
ich möchte heute wieder einen smoothie
machen und zwar gibt es heute einen
richtig exotischen trophy und zwar einen
ananas kokos mutti also pina colada
stein und ich brauche dafür eigentlich
nur zwei zutaten und zwar hier eine
reife ananas und eine kokosnuss eine
reife ananas erkennt ihr daran wenn ihr
halt diese blätter hier oben raus ziehen
könnt ohne so viel wie ok die hatte ich
schon ausgesucht und so gemacht aber die
hier lösen sich halt auch ganz leicht
und genau der hat jetzt die richtige
reife und jetzt müssen wir zuerst mal
die ananas knacken
die kokosnuss die kokosnuss knappen
meldung
und dass die anderen die cocos muss
meinen kopf das komme ganz durch die
kokosnuss hat hier drei löcher eins
davon ist etwas weicher das ist es hier
und das kann man jetzt also ich hab hier
so'n beraten thermometer sind fleisch
thermometer und das stecke ich jetzt
hier einfach mal rein
das mache ich aber noch ein zweites loch
denn wenn ich das jetzt ausfüllen also
aus gießen möchte gibt es fließt es halt
nicht gut weil es muss ja luft rein und
flüssigkeit raus deswegen ich probiere
mal ob es mit dem geld mit dem geht es
nicht also muss ich doch in einem hammer
taschen hammer bleibt dann brauche ich
dann abgebrochen
ich habe den hammer der separate genau
entweder können da jetzt einen
schraubendreher schraubendreher machen
und darauf hamann und hab da auch ein
loch oder dem rad geht mir jetzt einfach
der akku war natürlich zu geizig und
marketing aber das kinderbuch herkommt
es andere machen jetzt auch wieder
größer genau und jetzt kann ich das sehr
schön aus gießen
seht hier diese cocos flüssigkeit ich
jetzt nicht alles raus geht auch ganz
schnell
und jetzt müssen wir die einmal knacken
als ich wohne hier oben im dritten stock
deswegen schmeiße ich die kuris muss
jetzt einfach runter und dann knackt sie
auf
das heißt natürlich nur spaß natürlich
muss jeder von euch im dritten stock
deswegen zeige ich euch wie ihr die
cocos muss ganz einfach zu hause auch
machen könnte und zwar braucht ihr dafür
ein großes messer am besten wie sie
beide und da nehmen wir jetzt nicht die
schafe seite sondern die stumpfe und
jetzt müsst ihr die kokosnuss entweder
hinlegen oder in die hand nehmen und
jetzt immer so einen ganz leichten
schlag also so wird direkt mitten rein
müsst ihr euch wieso ein äquator denken
unterschlagen wird außen rum und dann
entsteht da jetzt gleichen riss und dann
habt ihr die kokosnuss perfekt in zwei
teile geteilt müsste es nur noch dieses
fruchtfleisch rausgekommen ist beruflich
bin ich habe zig kokosnuss ein bisschen
ausgewaschenen weil man kriegt ihr immer
von der schale aus ein bisschen was rein
und jetzt einfach das fruchtfleisch
lösen
ich nehme da jetzt so ein kleines messer
und schneidet mir das hier raus wir
können das hier am rand whistler lösen
und jetzt stehe ich hier noch diese
harte schale ab diese braune die kann
man zwar mit essen aber ich finde es
immer so ein bisschen störend vor allem
möchte ich jetzt keinen brown und snoopy
ja auch nicht schön aus deswegen
geschädigt es hier mit einem sparschäler
ab das klappt ganz gut
und dann weiß ich sie einmal noch kurz
ab und dann kann man gleich den smoothie
zu bereiten
und jetzt gebe ich schon mal die kokons
stück ich den blender rein wenn ihr halt
jetzt kein hochleistungs blender habt so
wie jetzt bei mir dann funktioniert es
eigentlich nicht das heißt ihr könnt
dann umschwenken und bräuchen auf
kokosmilch weil kokos fleisch ist das so
ziemlich fest und trocken das merkt man
auch wenn man das mal ist hängt es ab
und so gern mal im hals und deswegen
braucht ihr entweder den hochleistungs
mixa damit es richtig schön feiern wird
und cremig wird oder er nimmt halt
einfach direkt kokosmilch
ich gebe es hier ein bisschen wasser
rein so dass die mix messer mit wasser
bedeckt sind
das ist ja immer so sein es muss immer
so sein und dann stelle ich das hier
einfach mal auf höchster stufe 1
ok starter düsenjet
nach 20 sekunden sieht das ganze schon
so aus aber ihr seht dass es immer noch
ein bisschen flockig wie gesagt sind
kokosnüsse ziemlich hart und das fleisch
auch ziemlich trocken
das heißt ich möchte es jetzt noch ein
bisschen steine und lasst uns eben noch
ein bisschen länger mixen
der mix übrigens auch ziemlich laut aber
das ist alle hochleistungs mixa hat ja
auch zwei passt ja so als würde man der
vespa das wohnzimmer fahren jetzt nehme
ich die ananas und dafür brauche ich
jetzt nicht allzu viel deswegen nehme
ich mal so grob die hälfte diana das
erinnert mich an etwas was noch mal wir
alle nach diego ja stimmt ja leider
nichts gebracht denn der murat hat alles
gegessen auseinander
da gibt es eigentlich jedes jahr neu
damals war wird nicht in diesem jahr war
der ditip ananas essen also ja gut an
anders hat er diese enzyme und die regen
ja die fettverbrennung an und
unterstützen außerdem die 1
von daher ist es damit ganz falsch da
kommt jede woche eine neue neue neue die
neue tipp aber das mit der anlass ist
ein trojaner sich einig ist und der
frucht als ich halte von diäten nichts
wo man irgendwie zwei wochen lang nur
das gleiche ist aber ich finde ich das
ganz 100 gesunden ernährung schon wieder
zu dieser gab es diese wasserweg aber
nur wasser trinken kann ja so cool
fasten unsere zeugs machen
dieses jahr mehr um den körper zu
entschlacken morath diät so
normalerweise würde ich jetzt bei dem
normalen blender auch hier diesen strunk
wegschneiden jetzt einem hochleistungs
mixa können was drin lassen wobei ich
leiden jetzt doch weil ich habe ja auch
wahrscheinlich ein paar kunststückchen
mit drin deswegen schneide ich hätte
einen strunk erst mal weg vor allem
stieß er jetzt vom unteren teil ziemlich
hart jetzt vom oberen teil könne nichts
drin lassen
im sommer ganz unten drin lassen ja
jetzt dass ich vom unteren ende der
ananas und wissen kann ich aber jetzt
kommen hier die ananas stücke mit ran.de
du hättest du jetzt auch oben rein
machen können ja ich sage kleinschneider
müsse denn die öffnung wahrscheinlich so
groß dass ich meine hand da rein passt
oder die große us stücke reinpassen
da gebe ich aber gleich die eiswürfel
mit rein jetzt noch ein bisserl im
wasser
und während dem rühren gebe ich jetzt
oder während der mixen gebe ich jetzt
gleich noch die eiswürfel mit rein und
macht das ganze jetzt hier auf der
smoothie funktion
so wenn mir der smoothie jetzt etwas zu
langweilig deswegen habe ich mir
überlegt zu den hauptzutaten ananas
kokos jetzt auch noch ein paar bananen
dazu zu geben
vor allem muss ich dir jetzt so langsam
verwerten ich habe jetzt ein paar tage
legen lassen und bananen sind ja erst
dann richtig gut wenn sie außen eben
schön braun sind sind sie dann nämlich
richtig süß und es bringt jetzt meinem
smokie auch diese leckere süße mit rein
und auch diese cremigkeit also jetzt ist
das motiv so dass er etwas körperlich
aussieht eben wegen der kokosnuss aber
die banale bringt es gerade cremigkeit
mit rein bonner banana das geht kommt
jetzt einfach da oben mit rein
ich glaube ich nun mit 102
jetzt ist das motiv fertig muratow das
auch gleich probieren ja wir müssen auch
schnell machen ich muss noch samira
abholen kirchgang
die freuen sich bestimmt nebst die freut
sich nun über mir nicht gesagt papa du
schon wieder da was erwartet die das in
indien kommt vielleicht hat es sich
einfach mal verkleiden hat mini mit zwei
bananen hinterhand
es werden lässt du dir habe ich mach das
elegant mit einem röhrchen für die 2
aber da ist muss ich jetzt richtig schön
cremig durch die bananen ich hab jetzt
alle drei mit 1 gg beweisen dass derzeit
auch noch weg kommt sehr schick muss ich
jetzt richtig gelesen ich bin nach
richtig gut gehabt so neben die
grundsystem zumindest ja irgendwie auch
so ein milchshake konstanz sowie sem ich
würde eher sagen flug aus sagt bitte nie
wieder das wort glück ich nur einzelne
hässlichen wörter fluffig und dieses
risotto trotzig und lone star bash marie
die gehen gar nicht
aber was auf jeden fall geht es dieser
leckeres muti wie gesagt falls er keinen
sauerländer haft nehmen da einfach etwas
kokosmilch finde ich auch super vor
allem super lecker weil dann schaue ganz
mit kokosnuss mit drin
und ihr könnt da noch keine ahnung die
kinder und limette mit reingeben finde
ich auch gut hatte ich jetzt nur leider
keine da deswegen konnte ich sie nicht
mit rein machen auf jeden fall können
wir hier richtig kreativ sein und steht
es muss immer ausprobieren und ich
schreib das rezept aber natürlich noch
mal auf meinem blog auf facebook de und
freue mich wieder aufs nächste mal
er ist echt gut gefühlt als ich ganz
ehrlich sein